what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
explaining the latest
major villains in black clover and these
are
by far the strongest villains that we
have seen
up to this point all three members of
the dark triad
are possessed by a specific demon or
devil and that means that all three of
them have not one
but two different magic attributes
one that they were born with and one
that they gained as a result of being
possessed
by a demon we only recently found out
what all of these different magic
attributes are
so now we can finally discuss all of
their unique powers and abilities
in one video so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the black clover content
on this channel and you want to see more
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you happen to be new to anime pro
or maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications a big thank you to all
of our
anime uproar patrons for making videos
like this one possible
i'll talk more about patreon at the end
of the video but first
please be advised that this video will
contain black clover manga spoilers
i will be referring to all of the
currently available information about
the three members of the dark triad
including stuff in the manga that wasn't
yet covered in the anime so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned the dark triad is
made up of dante
xenon and vanica zogradus three siblings
and powerful devil possessed mages who
are the current rulers
of the spade kingdom the dark triad took
power by force
in the spade kingdom some 16 years ago
they attacked and overthrew the former
ruling house of the spade kingdom
the house grin burial whose last
remaining heir
is none other than you know after his
parents were killed by the dark triad
a baby juno was smuggled out of the
spade kingdom by people who
were still loyal to the grin burial
family in order to hide yuno from the
dark triad so that they couldn't kill
him
in order to eliminate the last grin
burial claimant
to the throne yuno was left at an
orphanage in hage village
which is located within the remote
forsaken realm
of the clover kingdom an orphanage in
the forsaken realm was the last place
that someone would think to look for a
prince of the spade kingdom
so yuno was successfully protected from
the dark triad
at least until the dark triad invaded
the diamond kingdom
and began expanding into the clover and
heart kingdoms
using the power of their devils or
demons the dark triad is exploiting the
citizens of the spade kingdom
in order to further their expansionist
goals
in fact the dark triad is known for
using citizens of the spade kingdom who
have low mana
as cheap sources of magic for powering
their mobile fortresses
the members of the dark triad also use
citizens of the spade kingdom who do
have a lot of mana
as dark disciples these are powerful
mages who serve directly
under the dark triad and who have the
ability to access a portion of a demon's
power
although they can't access nearly as
much power as members of the dark triad
themselves
finally although at first it might seem
like the dark triad is primarily
interested
in expanding the spade kingdom in
reality they have an even grander
and more devious goal their objective
is to open the tree of cliffhoth a
magical channel that would connect
this world and the demon world if the
tree of cliffhoth is opened
it will allow more demons to pour into
this world from their world
and this would also allow each member of
the dark triad to use
100 of their demons power until the
magical channel between the two worlds
is created
the dark triad members have to satisfy
themselves with using only 70 or 80
percent
of their demon's magic in order to open
the tree of cliffhoth the dark triad
needs to get their hands on two specific
magic attributes dark magic and
world tree magic the only known users of
these magic types in the world of black
clover are of course
yami sukahiro and william vongens
if the dark triad succeeds in opening
the tree of cliffhoth
the world as we know it would cease to
exist demons would destroy the world and
up to 90
of the world's population would be
exterminated and only the very strongest
would be able to survive
and now that we know the basics about
the dark triad
their backstory and their objectives
let's talk about the individual members
and their unique magic attributes the
first member of the dark triad that we
meet
is xenon and he makes quite the
impression
when we first see him he is able to
defeat an entire diamond kingdom
army on his own and he does it
seemingly without breaking a sweat xenon
is so impressive that even the absolute
mad lad luck voltea is intimidated by
him
which is a first in many ways xenon's
imposing introduction in chapter 227 of
the manga
and episode 129 of the anime sets the
stage for the entire spade kingdom war
arc
and it definitely gives us a good idea
about what to expect from the dark triad
in terms of power and combat ability as
a person
xenon seems to be serious ruthless and
all business unlike his siblings he
isn't interested in idol chit-chat or
having a good time
xenon wants to get the job done as
quickly and efficiently as possible
and he doesn't let anyone or anything
stand
in his way as you might expect from a
member of the dark triad
xenon can be extremely bloodthirsty when
the situation calls for it his original
magic attribute
the one that he was born with is bone
magic
xenon has the ability to create and
control sharp and deadly
bones and this includes the ability to
control many bones
at the same time as a result xenon is
able to use his bones to launch
vicious attacks at his opponents attacks
which include
multiple large and sharp bones flying at
the opponent
at the same time he can turn his bones
into weapons such as a spear or a sword
he can use the bones as a defensive
shield and he can also incapacitate his
opponents by
impaling them on his bones this allows
him to capture his opponents alive
if he so desires it is worth noting that
xenon's bone magic
is much stronger now than it was
originally because the power of his
demon
increases the power of his original
magic and this is the case with all
three members
of the dark triad xenon's second magic
attribute
the one that he gained from his demon is
a very interesting form of spatial magic
as the name suggests spatial magic can
be used to
alter the space around you and we have
seen xenon using spatial magic to create
portals which allow him to appear at a
place of his choosing
seemingly out of nowhere this enables
xenon to sneak up on his opponents
before they even realize that he is
there
and we have already seen xenon using
this ability with great effectiveness
in chapter 260 of the manga xenon also
appears to be able to create some sort
of protective cube
around his body xenon spatial magic is
the last out of the six
dark triad magic attributes to be
revealed
so our overall understanding of this
magic
attribute is still pretty limited as of
the making of this video
without the tree of cliffhoth xenon is
able to access
up to 80 percent of his demon's power
next up we have vanica the only female
member of the dark triad
vernica is somewhat of a psychotic
dominatrix
and her dark disciples in particular
appear to be massive
simps they love and worship vanica as
the greatest creature to ever live
but vanica considers the dark disciples
to be completely expendable
something that she demonstrates in
chapter 255
of the manga in terms of personality
vanica
is driven by the love of a good fight
and the desire to have fun
by taking on the strongest possible
opponents
her love of a good fight and her search
for stronger opponents
kind of reminds me of goku from dragon
ball and just like with goku
this love of a good challenge can
sometimes get in the way
of vanica's greater goals for example
even though vernica's initial mission
was to kill loro pachika the queen of
the heart kingdom
she decided to keep loro pechika alive
in order to motivate noel to become
stronger
so that noel can give manika a fun fight
sometime in the future
this is the type of thing that xenon
would never do at least that's what it
seems like to me
so in this sense xenon and vanica appear
to be very different
with that said vanica is also committed
to the tree of clifforth plan
vanika especially likes this plan
because it is likely to lead to the
destruction of 90
of the world's population and so when
everything is said and done
only the strongest mages will survive
this demon apocalypse
vanika likes this idea because she
despises weaklings
and she wants to live in a world where
only the strongest can survive
vanica's original magic attribute is
blood magic
which allows her to create and control
blood
she is able to make giant monsters made
of blood that look like something right
out of stranger things
and she can then use these monsters
against her opponents
in battle vanika's second magic
attribute
the one that she gained from her demon
megicula is
curse magic vanica is able to create
devastatingly strong and resilient
curses
and one of her curses is said to have
killed noel's mother
aussie a silva vanica and megicula were
also able to curse loro pechika
and unless this curse is removed loro
pechika will die
within a few months time vanika is also
able to place curses on her
own dark disciples including a curse
that allows them to come back to life
no matter how many times they are killed
which is absolutely broken
and incredibly overpowered and a curse
that makes these same dark disciples
literally explode if vanica decides that
they are no longer useful to her
vanica is able to access up to 70
percent
of her demon's power and according to
laura pacheca
vaneka's demon megicula is stronger than
the word magic demon
zagred the final member of the dark
triad
and their apparent leader is dante
when we first meet him dante seems like
a pretty relaxed
and light-hearted guy he jokes around he
smiles frequently
and even asks attractive women with
powerful magic like vanessa and gray to
become
his women in that sense dante's outward
persona
couldn't be more different than xenons i
really can't picture xenon trying to
pick up girls
during one of his missions however once
dante is introduced
it doesn't take long for his truly
psychotic side to come out
as a young man dante was bored with life
and he didn't know what to do with
himself
nothing made him feel alive and in order
to deal with this
existential malaise he tried everything
from sleeping with women to killing
animals to killing people
to burning cities but nothing seemed to
work
it was only after he embraced his insane
ideology about humanity
that he became the fun-loving psycho
that he is today
dante is convinced that human nature is
inherently
evil but human beings are always
fighting against that natural instinct
which makes the world boring dante
believes that being evil
is a good thing that being evil means
being true to your nature
and for him the best thing a human being
can do
is embrace their inner evil and embrace
their malice
as their truest and most honest emotion
as such dante likes to provoke his
opponents
into embracing their darkest emotions
and he thinks that being called evil
is actually a compliment dante's
original magic
is body magic or flesh magic this magic
attribute allows him to manipulate the
flesh of his body to a massive extent
and dante's appearance becomes so
grotesque when he uses this magic
that he prefers not using it at all and
so he only uses it when he feels like he
has no
other choice body magic enables dante to
regenerate
almost instantly which means that he can
heal himself from virtually any injury
this includes extremely severe injuries
like being decapitated or losing his
entire torso
clearly this is an incredibly
overpowered ability and it is immensely
useful in battle
as we saw during dante's fight against
tiami and asta
and if this super regeneration wasn't op
enough
dante's body magic also apparently
allows him to stop the aging process
completely which means that dante can
theoretically live forever we can assume
that his original body magic wasn't
this overpowered but after being
enhanced by the demon lucifer
it has become easily one of the most
broken magic attributes
in black clover the only real weakness
of body magic appears to be asta's
anti-magic
only a direct hit with an anti-magic
attack can bring dante down and stop him
from regenerating
dante's second magic attribute the one
that he got from lucifer
is gravity magic gravity magic allows
dante to control
gravity and he can do everything from
making himself fly
by weakening the gravity around him to
making objects and people heavier
forcing them to fall to the ground or
forcing them to move from one spot to
another he can also use gravity magic to
create
powerful weapons and projectiles
including swords
finally dante can make himself faster
and stronger by manipulating the gravity
around him
so for example his own punches can
become heavier
and faster because they are being
enhanced by the gravity around them
like xenon dante can access up to 80
percent
of his demon's power the dark triad are
by far the strongest villains that we
have seen
in black clover so far their access to
demon magic
and their ability to use two separate
magic attributes
make them the most hopey villains in the
series up to this point
if i were to make an educated guess i
would guess that vanica is the weakest
because she could only access 70 percent
of her demon's power
then i would put dante above her and
finally i would put xenon
at the top of the list even though dante
is apparently the leader we have seen
that he can be defeated
whereas xenon is undefeated and his
feats and accomplishments have been more
impressive than dante's
i also think that xenon is much more
focused than dante
and this can definitely work to his
advantage in battle
but this ranking is just my speculation
we've never actually seen dante and
xenon fight
so it's impossible to know which one of
them would win let me know what you guys
think
do you like the dark triad as villains
and which of the three
is your favorite also how would you rank
the three dark triad members
in terms of power and who do you think
is the strongest
feel free to leave your thoughts down in
the comments below
if you enjoyed this video you want to
see more blacklover content
right here on the channel please leave a
like to let me know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to animeopro
or you just haven't subscribed yet don't
forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all i know it's annoying but unless you
do that you're still gonna miss a lot of
our videos
even if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
for making videos like this one possible
a very special thank you to alpha sigma
a disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata alolan
adam the world
acquired respect pate heffa jonathan
king
brandon aviles papa smurf emperor otaku
thomas jones kid mono and
admirath finally thank you to all of our
pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan jason wilson king
zeldris anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia octor
jessica calefon
hinokami and water bonnie parks ratheora
florian
joni garcia steelers deadly saint and
stern hawkins
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear
in our videos along with these legendary
people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you